you tweet something when you're not
totally sober
and you have to reckon with what happens
and i'm a man of my word
i've approached this series with a lot
of trepidation because
it seems like everyone who recommends
wheel of time they say yeah it's great
but there are these books that are slow
and it has a slower pace and you have to
deal with this
and it was finished by a different
author now it's finished by brandon
sanders and i have no issue with that
nobody hates star wars more than star
wars fans i feel like nobody
hates wheedle time more than the wheel
of time fans
i'm excited because this is such a huge
fantasy monument like reading the whole
series has become this kind of like
herculean
task which i think is kind of silly
i'm a kind of person i really like
slower
fantasy and i've gotten about halfway
through the first book what surprises me
about starting the wheel of time is how
how comfortable it feels
a lot of people say well it's just a
tolkien ripoff especially the first book
well guess what
i haven't read lord of the rings so
i can just enjoy it i started reading
the eye of the world and i went oh
okay i get it even just like the slow
scenes at the beginning walking around
with these characters preparing for a
festival
in some ways is more fun than some of
the action scenes
feeling uh you know of the senses the
sensory details it's very
immersive i'm just excited i don't know
what else to say like
look at this book this is the special
edition i took off the silver cover
because i thought it
didn't look as great but i mean got this
beautiful color map
you know something about diving into a
new fantasy world
and learning everything about it and
just feeling like the possibilities are
endless it's my favorite thing and
here's the ques here's the question
though do i get
all of the 14 15 books i mean do i buy
them all in hardcover this is like a big
book and it's just one book you know
all 14 books i mean i guess if there's
peer pressure like maybe
yeah i mean it'll be interesting i think
after reading the series to come back
and watch this
and see maybe how naive i am
like oh i'm i'm reading will of time now
do you love me do you respect me now dad
we're gonna have a
fun time a fun time
what was i thinking